do you guys remember this I got a
joystick I've got a helmet that's right
and you just put the helmet on like that
or this or even this it came from the
third dimension digital brain see this
was Villar when I was growing up it's
only know much if it was only accessible
by spending ten or twenty bucks at the
mall arcade or through the magic of
filmmaking and post-production it looks
kind of cool right I mean granted I was
just 10 years old and in terms of
computer tech the 90s was like an age
where the general public was in awe of
everything the internet arcade machines
Wolfenstein 3d pagers you name it it got
attention anyways VR is back and once
again making the rounds but don't worry
this is not just another video where I'm
going to [ __ ] all over this current VR
craze know they'll be no comparing it to
fads of the early 90s which let's face
it vr didn't really amount to anything
no this is about how we present the
current state of VR to you to the
audience and why it's so difficult to
show you an experience that really can't
be understood it will felt just by
watching a bunch of people do this they
all look like idiots right I mean all of
us do because let's face it this is new
to us there is no true base comparison
here we've spent over 30 years playing
games with joysticks keyboards and
gamepads if I were to show something
like this to my dad he probably just
start to question my career so let's
slow down for a minute and take a small
step back how would you explain to
someone in 1920 what it felt like to fly
or how about telling someone in the 50s
what it felt like the sky dive or [ __ ]
just tell someone in the 80s that in
just under 20 years everyone will have a
small device that allows them to talk to
anyone anywhere on the planet truth is
you really can't
I mean you can try just like will try to
show you all sorts of VR game demos and
as much as we hear that we either liked
it or didn't there just isn't much you
can relate to I mean I can try out a new
car and tell you that it's life-changing
and you may get it you know you can look
at the specs and look at all the
test-drive videos all you want but you
know what driving a car is like you know
it may pique your curiosity but with VR
you have to experience it plain and
simple game demos do very little to show
you how it feels watching some random
dude flails arms around like a crazy
person isn't going to show you the
immersive experience or lack thereof and
I bring this up because recently we got
a vibe in the game spot office and my
first question was how do we show this
to you how do we show you that it's fun
how do we show you that it's not fun we
faced a similar dilemma back in two
thousand six with the week but even with
motion controls people can relate to the
motion of bowling or playing tennis it's
probably one of the reasons why the wii
was so popular with non-traditional
gamers in the first place they could
relate to it but with VR it's tough you
know we have a few of Bismil failures in
the late 80s and early 90s and then some
fun sci-fi flicks but that's it now
we're at a whole new level earlier this
week I went to a huge oculus VR demo
here in SF it was the perfect event to
begin GDC this event had dozens of the
our game demo kiosk set up you know
little rooms we can try all sorts of
games etc our problem is it should be
you going to these events not just us we
can show you all the videos of people
waving their arms around looking lost we
want but it's not going to do much to
get you excited about VR oculus knows
this HTC in valve notice Sony knows this
that's why you'll see these giant you
know vr tour trucks making their way
across the country trying to show people
V are you know just to get you to try it
because like everything else that is new
that is how VR is going to succeed
you'll try it you like it you tell a
friend
wow this place is great when can we move
in you've gotta try this poll so if you
get the chance give it a world you know
make up your own mind do your research
do your due diligence but just
experience it because nothing I can say
or do will paint the picture of what VR
is actually like it's like being in love
or being heartbroken hard to convey easy
to feel so just feel it I love you
you